ceux qui quittent la ville pour la
campagne le font souvent pour les beaux
paysages la quiétude des lieux dans le
reportage qui suit des néoruraux
retroussent leurs manches adopté
l'agriculture et contribuer du même coup
à la vitalité régionales
[Musique]
et
j'étais pendant 37 ans jusqu'à liste
après toutes ces années là bas j'avais
le goût de faire d'autres choses j'avais
le goût de la l'appel de la nature
c'est vrai que j'avais de jeunesse
d'avoir une ferme puis c'est la vie qui
m'a amené ici finalement
à nos produits
on était bien établir toutes ces
personnes ont un lien en commun elles
ont toutes choisi de quitter la ville et
de s'établir à bolton west dans les
cantons de l'est et surtout d'adopter
l'agriculture comme mode de vie
[Musique]
quand je suis arrivé ici à 25 ans je
tombe en amour avec les vaches lise
boucher s'est lancé dans l'élevage de
vaches highland j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer un voisin qui avait ses
vaches là que je me décide de partir un
petit troupeau
c'est une vache est quand même très
rustique facile pour beaucoup de
problèmes de santé chez cet animal la
fois mâle blanc ça c'est du ccdh
émotionnellement maintenant grâce à son
expérience elle est de nouvelles
arrivantes nancy lanteigne qui à son
tour soit élevé un troupeau
donc on aurait pu dire non laisse aller
c'est un buzz qui resort qui est quand
même assez facile mais beaucoup de
petites choses à savoir donc je pense
pas que j'ai regardé je compterai dit ok
on va les vents depuis mais de savoir
que j'avais quelqu'un qui pouvait
m'aider ça fait au conseil le second il
va
[Musique]
ouais
en plus des vaches highland nancy
lanteigne et son conjoint ont démarré un
projet d'apiculture
on travaille beaucoup avec l'apithérapie
aussi dont les produits de la pêche tous
les produits là je sais pas seulement
lumière
non qu'on a la propolis le pôle m
là c'est donc tous les produits donc
c'est ça qu'on veut encore une très
bonne qualité passait tout des
productions consommables
[Musique]
robert demers lui s'est lancé dans la
production maraîchère on se demandait
qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'un grand terrain
comme ça puis
ma blonde m'a acheté un livre sur
l'agriculture maraîchère puis l'eau ça a
commencé à mijoter dans ma tête
jamais aucune aucune connaissance du
haut niveau avec l'école soit dont j'ai
commencé à côtoyer des jeunes à des
vrais de vrais agriculteurs
donc c'est un apprentissage accéléré
aujourd'hui il produit et vend une
trentaine de légumes en régie biologique
c'est surtout du bouche à oreille j'ai
presque parfaite de publicité puis je
vends aussi à des restaurants du coin
ghana
[Musique]
ses voisins partager si la même passion
de l'agriculture mais pour ces citadins
devenu fermier à temps plein l'aide est
le partage de connaissances sont la clé
du succès d'un projet agricole
est ici depuis quelques années cette
idée de partage entre voisins a un nom
le collectif bolton ouest la notion du
troc voilà ce que je produis voilà ce
que tu produis on s'échange ce bénéfice
est à besoin d'un coup maintenant ce
côté on appellerait ça un peu le gros
bon sens paysan mais c'est à dire qu'est
ce que je peux faire pour toi tu
t'y es ce qu'on peut faire tout ça
ensemble au profit du lâche donc c'est
un peu s'investir dans cette mission là
sur qu'est-ce que je peux faire
au profit de tous meriem brel fait aussi
partie du collectif bolton west mais
elle ne pratique pas l'agriculture elle
prête l'espace de son terrain à son
voisin et 10 qui lui vient faucher les
foins moi je mets à profit avec moi mon
terrain lui il met à profit son
expertise donc finalement on se rejoint
pour être productif un ensemble et
pouvoir alimenter effectivement les
animaux du coin aussi
4 collectif est arrivé mais moi ça m'a
aidé pour la vente de viande on essaye
de faire une économie opus circulaire
que ce soit l'élevage de boeuf la
culture fourragère la production de
légumes de miel ou de sirop d'érable
chaque membre apporte son expertise et
son aide dans le but de favoriser
l'agriculture locale on partage aussi
les coûts que ce soit des expertises
agronomique ou pour l'achat de divers
produits c'est vrai pour la chaux la
chaux est un produit de base et obtenu
effectivement pied et non c'est une
entente pour une offre un
approvisionnement de chaux pour non
seulement l'ensemble des membres du
collectif mais l'ensemble de plusieurs
personnes du village d'as et c'est des
choses que un fermier lui même n'aurait
pas nécessairement la capacité de faire
tout seul
on a fait faire une étude à plusieurs
pour savoir le potentiel des produits
forestiers non ligneux
de nos forêts donc quelqu'un qui analyse
et nous nos plans d'aménagement
forestier qu'on l'avait fait faire aussi
en groupe pour déterminer c'était quoi
le potentiel
si on est seul il arrive toujours des
pépins et toujours un petit quelque
chose donc si on sait qu'on est un
équipe on a des gens avec nous qu'ils
sont là pour nous aider qui sont là pour
nous informer son chef des erreurs
coiffeur pourquoi société arriver mais
en ce moment là c'est un gros stress de
moi
derrière cette idée de partage du
collectif il y a aussi une notion fort
importante pour le village la
revalorisation de l'agriculture et
surtout un entretien du paysage agricole
pour des gens qui venaient de la ville
de montréal comme nous qui étions pas
pressenti effectivement pour faire de la
culture que ce soit l'entretien d'un
boisé où que ce soit l'entretien d'une
culture ça vient nous alimenter
personnellement j'ai comme un devoir
pour mes enfants puis pour l'ensemble de
la communauté a à l'entretenir
intelligent
[Musique]
notre but est un but à l'herbe donc il
n'y a pas de grille pas douter un mieux
peau
nos abeilles c'est la même chose c'est
notre meilleur on n'est point qu'il ya
pas de pesticides dans le coin on n'a
pas de monoculture qu'utilise le
pesticide
cette idée d'économie circulaire a
permis de relancer une agriculture qui
était en perte de vitesse à bolton ouest
si bien qu'aujourd'hui le collectif
regroupe maintenant une trentaine de
membres et plus de mille sept cent
cinquante hectares en culture
en étant en constante recherche
développement chacun sur des idées
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme culture
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire comme les
produits forestiers non ligneux les
idées des idées fusent de part et
d'autre c'est clair qu'il ya une
ébullition de sujets puis d'initiative
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire moi j'ai eu
le goût de faire ça hop tout pourrait
faire ça que la complémentarité puis où
on va plus loin
elle expose la 4l ici dans la région je
connais plus de monde que j'en ai connu
pendant 25 ans demeurer à montréal
semi détaché avec du monde colis à côté
de chez nous il obtient donc c'est tout
ce qui fait en sorte que là c'est
l'agriculture c'est le côté
communautaire ses côtés social c'est
toujours comme ça
ça va être vraiment la survie c'est
vraiment la force du groupe donc c'est
l'humain au mieux de ses capacités
[Musique]
c'est gaza